le lundi de pâques est une journée
unique la seule du calendrier à
bénéficier d'un tel statut c'est le seul
jour férié de l'année que rien ne
justifie on commémore aucune victoire
aucun événement national
on ne célèbre aucune fête religieuse le
lundi de pâques
il ne s'est absolument rien passé alors
pourquoi ce jour et qu'il fait rien il
faut remonter au moyen âge pour trouver
la réponse à cette époque il n'y avait
pas que le lundi pas que le lundi la
semaine en pierre etaix chômé cette
période baptisée l'octave était
consacrée au pèlerinage une sorte de
capsule 2d confinés comme les gens se
déplacer à pied il valait mieux prévoir
large
c'est napoléon bonaparte qui a sonné le
glas de l'octave en réduisant cette
période aux seuls lundi de pâques
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce vous
pouvez également voir ou revoir les
vidéos précédentes en cliquant sur les
côtés en haut ou en bas je réalise une
nouvelle chaque jour pour être sûr de ne
rater aucune vous pouvez vous abonner et
activer la petite cloche aller à demain
et n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lien